és akkor utána eljött a kétfé egy olyan
pontra hogy oké ezt gondolom én ezt
gondolod te és akkor van valami alapján
ami ami alapján egységet teremtsünk mert
megbeszéltük a dolgokat én azt gondolom
hogy például romániában is meg
magyarországon ez az egyik fő probléma
hogy hogy az egység azért nincs mert
mert az emberek nem elég konfrontatívak
nem eléggé válják fel a véleményüket
egymásra például nagyon hangosak
facebookon de de lustán kienni tüntetni
és ez ez okozza azt ez ez okozza azt a
látszólag ellentmondásos dolgot hogy én
izraelben több mosolygó embert látok
mint magyarországon vagy
romániában az emberek sokkal
pozitívabbak és ez nem egy ilyen nem egy
ilyen hogy is mondjam hamis pozitív
pozitívság hanem hanem mivel lerendeztük
a konfliktusokat kibeszéltük a
problémáinkat nem kell magunkba fot
fojtsuk tehát mondjam úgy hogy nem
rthhat semmi érzel ünk ami miattzmálun
kellene ezért megengedhetjük magunknak
hogy mosolygk tehát én úgy látom hogy e
az összefüggés
[Zene]